[Music]
hi I'm Mike say mo from FX guide.com
for wired Captain America is back and so
is the Helicarrier from Avengers or
should I say three helicarrier's it's
easy to become blasé about some of these
complex shots but to achieve shots at
this level is such an incredible
attention to detail the texture detail
alone on the new ships is four times
that of Avengers Industrial Light and
Magic were tasked with updating and
upgrading shields most impressive
airborne assets and we spoke to Bruce
Holcomb who supervised the building of
the new helicarriers when we were first
approached to do the work it seemed like
there weren't too many events that were
happening and the Helicarrier that we
had from the Avengers was going to be
just a small upgrade and then by the
time of course we reached through the
middle part of the production there were
three of them this scale I think
increased by maybe a fourth but the
enormity of how many shots we had were
things that we were definitely not
prepared for and then the scope of the
movie centered around a lot of that for
example the quinjets these are on each
of the carriers and every one of these
jets is modeled in text so carefully and
yet they're just a tiny part of a shot
like this having a wrangle as heavy as
those were on top of the deck because
they're on every shot you know I'm just
like I fodder now like nobody even cares
and when the helicarrier's are crashing
all these things are falling off the
side and stuff and just laughing it but
they just became like a non-issue so
let's look a bit more closely as to
what's going on in a shot in fact how
much of the shot do you think is real
because we know the Helicarrier is 3d
and then there's the simulation of it
hitting the 3d model of the building the
smoke is all digital in addition each
window is modeled and then shattered as
of course is the debris in fact all of
this is digital 3d animation want to see
the only live-action in the shot Falcon
was shot on a green screen and then
placed in a 3d set which was just here
on the building then there's a digital
version of Washington that was placed
around the
building now we call back in the carrier
add those layers of smoke debris finally
add some atmosphere some camera shake
and here's the final shot the actors are
the stars of the film and rightly so the
next time you watch an effect sequence
like this have a thought for the digital
modelling guys and the environment that
they provide
of course modeling is just part of the
process but in case you think that we
impress easily I'm going to leave you
with Bruce who by the way still be
adding detailing if he could I would
have loved to just kept building this
thing until it somebody fired me but in
some shots I went into dailies and I
literally said well out loud because
some of the shots that they have it in
it and it's just so real there don't
forget to subscribe for more behind the
scenes action I'm Mike Seymour for wide
you
[Music]